my name is ulema mabini Masekela they
call me Sal for short and my film was
called Alakazam now it's a
father-and-son story yeah my dad was a
political exile from South Africa sort
of an activist making music all over the
world but couldn't make music at home
and I was born in the States
you know as a sort of child of exile and
then with my dad skateboarders and so
the film's really just about a little
bit of my father's journey and then my
journey enough to finally deciding it
that it was time for me to do something
I haven't put an awful music so it
started off from making this album and
somehow this beautiful form came
now were there years where you did not
know you know my dad like I said he was
he was exiled he couldn't go homeless
South Africa but he wanted to make music
with African musicians so he went to
places like it's wanna into the Bob way
and West Africa for like five years
you know from about ten to fifteen I
didn't really see him when we wrote
letters and things like that you know
it's it's interesting when you when
you're a kid you know
you wanna do that your fans but I as I
got older I was able to understand what
it was if he was doing and what he was
fighting for and really for him it was
always about the music being an
instrument to help raise awareness about
South Africa and eventually the end of
the party so you have a foundation right
that helps at-risk kids yes okay
and wouldn't you see other parallel I
grew up without a dad - so what do you
see as sort of a parallel a lot of these
kids well the thing that I see what the
kids have with my organization with
stoked is that all they really want is
opportunities you know and a lot of
times they're missing a parent in their
life that's the consistent thing they're
missing usually a father figure and so
these kids being able to have someone a
mentor that they have the opportunity on
a skateboard there's no more research to
do things outside of their box it takes
their horoscope on life and it changes
it around they all of a sudden have
opportunities and they're in new
environments comfortable their
self-esteem so yeah
yeah what do you want people to take
away from masses want people to take
away from I think you know for me your
parents are the good friend of who you
want we all go through different times
with our parents I have friends who
haven't talked to their parents and
years and I'm just lucky that I that I
got mine that I was able to get my dad
and have him stay in my life and went
through some hardships but he's my best
friend so if anything I hope that it
makes you know kids think about their
parents and parents think about their
kids because it's the one journey that
we all have